there are pockets of despair all over
this city this is the Mercure hotel
where the victims are still being
discovered
I'm Asha Brora mistress I'm a services
llama drama poppin smoker to an American
booty shotter Sonia sama sobrarbe to
token opposition stress ecology humming
six months on the seafront it was a
direct hit for the tsunami and for
another day it's been one of so many
focuses for rescuers our journey in on
an aid convoy was from the west up along
silhoue C's northern coastal road the
route that was only reached by rescuers
a day earlier the positive news from
here at least is that despite the
violence of the quake the damage and
loss of life was just a fraction of what
they'd feared hundreds have moved up to
higher ground here these are some of the
70,000 people now without a home they
need food water and fuel - everywhere
there is a pump hundreds wait some of
the roads in - Paulo are still blocked
the real and slides and with hundreds of
aftershocks there's still the danger of
more diggers are in short supply and all
the rescue vehicles here need fuel in
the village of siggy outside Paulo
they've been digging at this school for
days now and Martin kibou has been
waiting they think my son won't come
back he says I come back here every day
he's living with impossible hope
the president was here today he was
shown the recovery at the city's roarr
roarr Hotel a voice was heard earlier
some hope still maybe this is his second
visit
but the aide he's promised still isn't
getting through in the quantity needed
as dusk falls we explore more of the
city well just under half of the petrol
stations in this city have now been
restocked but take a look at this one
the queues to get fuel are really huge
the contents of the shops here is in
front of them pushed through by the
force of the wave from behind there are
pockets here of total destruction and in
other areas largely untouched back at
the RORO a hotel where the president was
earlier work has stopped for the night
before we just spoken to the owner of
the hotel and he says that seven bodies
were recovered today but he thinks that
there could be the remains of up to 30
more people still inside but they've not
heard any more sounds there is no hope
it's thought of anyone else being alive
in here mark stone Sky News in Paulo
Indonesia